it literally is like a factory for
producing product producing more
products containing numerous dead
puppies never seen an area of animal
crime explode in the way the puppy
farming has over the last five years and
they're destroyed by drowning or by
shooting or by walling in we hear horror
stories all the time of poppy farmers
sort of just opening the the breeding
[ __ ] up on the kitchen table with a
knife no everyone's the same we'll go
through that again I will see tears is
to get these dogs and give them a life
because they haven't got one previously
is a carrier bag what appears to be a
dead puppy everything that potentially
could go wrong with a tiny little fluffy
puppy could or will go wrong there right
now while we're talking there are dogs
in agony so someone can have a puppy now
hello is it is it Richard but my setup
says I should be with you
between quarter and help us three is are
still okay I'll see you shortly okay bye
now we're on our way to Richard Kendall
he's been dealing in puppies for many
years he's licensed certainly there have
been lots of puppies over the years that
have been sick puppies and lots of
unhappy customers we want to meet him
and see what he's doing and let's see
what puppies he's got for sale one of
the main points of going to see puppy
dealers is to get them to speak freely
about what it is that they do and one of
the things that allows us to do is to
check that against their license
conditions
[Music]
I'll turn around her
hi Richard they aren't criminals they
are fraudsters they want to make as much
money as they can and they don't care if
they kill however many puppies along the
way they will just do it the whole puppy
issue is a massive problem across the
whole of the UK supported by the police
to find a wheelbarrow containing
numerous dead puppies I've worked for
the RSPCA for 24 years now and I've
never seen an area of animal crime
explode in the way that puppy farming
has over the last five years there are
more and more people getting involved
and it just seems to be feeding the
demand for these dogs is it's really
very similar to drug dealing except
without the risk and nearly quite as
alliterative because if you bring in
hundreds or thousands of dogs throughout
the year and you can sell each one for
anywhere between five hundred and a
thousand pounds for a minimal out like
that's that's high profit and that's
what drives this business it literally
is like a factory floor producing
products producing more product
please dump that battery farm and then
the situation they're born these puppies
are born into is as farm animals they're
being fed with sort of pig feeders and
sprinkler systems so they're not even
kept in the dark a lot of them in wild
pink boxes so the perhaps are removed
too young they're nice and cute and
fluffy they make great pictures online
if indeed that is their picture online
and there's nothing more emotive I don't
think to the British public or any
member of any public any country than a
puppy because there's such an urgency to
sell these pups and the condition their
own in again it's all negative factors
that end up affecting so many lives from
the breeding [ __ ] to the new owners and
to the puppies themselves and these dogs
are that they're not really they're not
allowed to be dogs they're just they're
just machines for producing money thanks
so much thank you Richard bye
so the puppies we saw today at richer
Kendall's it was mainly for West D
puppies we also saw a Cavalier King
Charles puppy it looked a bit subdued
and a little bit flat and then there was
a rather unusual cross a Cavalier cross
with a Shiba Inu and there were public
seem to be coming from everywhere
Richard isn't the first puppy dealer
that we've tried to set up a visit with
we have been trying for some time to
have a look at the puppies that are
being advertised by a puppy dealer
called Stacey Hayward I saw your ad is a
couple of weeks ago now in pets for
homes just hold if you haven't still got
any available have you there is a
connection between richard kendall puppy
dealer and also stacy hayward what we
understand is that stacy hayward buys
most of if not all of her puppies that
she then resells from Richard Kendall so
we we believe that they know each other
well they have a long established
working relationship together and here
we are what you have to remember these
people are con artists they aren't
saying how to dupe that buyer into them
handing over their cash for an animal
they know nothing about and that seller
knows ultimately that there's a high
risk that that dog is going to fall ill
so I've been on puppy farms so if you
know if you slip it right back and you
actually see the state of the breeding
[ __ ] that the state of the puppies
and it's really sad because you have
dogs that are cowering in the corner you
have dogs with clearly in pain clearly
suffering and then of course when you're
not fertile anymore and you're
technically useless to the puppy farmer
they're destroyed and they're destroyed
by drowning or by shooting or by walling
in or other ways and
another problem but we see as cesareans
you know of course so you've got a
situation where what do they do do they
seek veterinary help or do they go for
it themselves and we hear horror stories
all the time of poppy farmers sort of
just opening the the breeding [ __ ] up
on the kitchen table with a knife
because if you've got eight puppies
inside they're going to be sold for one
to two grand it's you know it's more
beneficial to have that though the
breeding they'll die and keep the
puppies so when we when we talk about
unscrupulous unethical immoral we mean
it because there's nothing there's
nothing positive about puppy farming
for us it's been a very difficult
decision to make
do we carry on taking these dogs that if
we don't take them are going to die or
do we take them and almost in some way
it sort of feels as if you're supporting
the system although you're not
and tonight we're off to Kemal Bern and
we're going to be picking up just one
dog tonight
from a puppy farm breeder this one is
being used for breeding but she's been
diagnosed with a heart condition and
will have get it to the vets as soon as
we can
have the heart condition diagnosed find
out if there's anything we can do to
make it better and if not we'll just
find out what treatment she needs to
give her as good a quality of life as we
possibly can for as long as we can I
never quite know what's going to happen
and it and it could be that I get a
phone call in it has to be that day or
it might be the following day but it's
usually within a few days the dogs have
to be moved and numbers can vary as well
I'm like today tonight I'm picking up
one but it could be 5 6 8 it really
depends I don't always know where I'm
going I'll meet someone in a lay-by or
in a car park or a service station and
the dogs get handed over and they don't
really know anything about me and I
don't know anything about them so
there's a lot of anonymity with it
good Johnny
right this is the little dog I've just
picked up now from the puppy farm she's
quite young she's only about two and
she's had one litter she's in relatively
good condition she's got a heart murmur
and that's why she's been given in but
if she keeps having puppies that's gonna
get worse and also if it's a hereditary
condition she could pass it on to her
puppies next is home and really just
getting a used to being off a farm
because she won't have been away from a
farm before then it'll be off to the
vets to have a health check and see if
we can get some idea of what's causing
the heart problem rehabilitating her
working with a building of confidence
and gaining her trust I know lots of dog
owners and I know lots of dog lovers
they're not the same people so I think
if we are to be a nation of dog lovers
we need to rethink who has dogs and
who's fit to have dogs that's a really
difficult one to solve
puppy farming's probably the worst it's
ever been in this country and and that
is because to a degree with sleep walked
into a situation that could have been
avoided
it's also been allowed to happen in
other ways you know the government's
advices to see a puppy with the mum in
the place where the puppy was born but
at the same time the same government
allows people to buy them hundreds of
miles away by allowing puppies to be on
the pet shop license the other pet shop
license that allows this trade to
flourish are the ones that operate in a
room like this a home any other dwelling
but then they buy in puppies from other
puppy farms and then how on earth a
person can tell whether they've homebred
them or they bred them themselves it's
it's just it's like playing Russian
roulette for a puppy by now but we are
looking at some more puppies on Thursday
I don't know exactly what they are for
now she's just said she's looking at a
lot okay she's gonna pick which ones
like one time she went out for some Jack
Jack and I just never just legal will it
just as they come in and like right so
what we got you're dealing with a level
of damage that we as animal lovers
should be utterly ashamed of that is
happening in licensed and unlicensed
establishments and then there are the
puppies who will probably if you're
lucky survive you know for a few years
maybe longer and if you're really
unlucky and so many people are they will
be dead within days or hours of you
purchasing them we have forked into a
mind minefield
of k9 disaster that is really not the
way we should be doing things whether
with our companion animals but the rest
of it is just pure heartbreak
to know that these aren't the early dogs
the suffering yeah they're right now
while we're talking there are dogs in
agony so someone can have a puppy now
and if they're our most cherished
companion animal is being so badly
abused what does it say about what's
happening to the rest of the animal
population we can't really be kind to
ourselves until we can be kind to
animals and respect them
the gorgeous-looking Dogma ought to all
be secure but it was just it was just
something about him he had really long
eyelashes and big brown eyes you were
just strumming he's beautiful
I look from the internet it looks on
gumtree pets for home the time are
called the dogs had already been taken
because King Charles Cavaliers are
popular dogs so then dr. oz came up and
they were fairly local and I just went
down to the shop and so Winston fell in
love in stress went and picked something
took him home a bit of time before an
artist that things weren't we Winston it
started with the head nodding and then
he started with his with his first domed
seizure may actually went unconscious
and at that point I actually I didn't
know what to do I was I'm flush the
screaming down the father to the vets
and then when he came out of it didn't
know who were worse and he was how old
and he was crying and then he actually
just bit through in ham there and then I
came home again that night and I was
just done I was on tender hooks and he
had another major fit at 9 o'clock that
night
what's fit in my eyes just went on
forever it was horrific
I've never seen anything like it don't
ever once seen with Ron and we'll go
through that again I would I was in
tears I was literally in tears it was
it's the most setting thing because an
animal can't tell you what's matter but
they such philosophy yard he knew about
her because he cried he cried that poor
dog cried for half an hour and I know I
was I was in tears when the vets is here
and I know why it's important sleep they
weren't like typical puppies at all who
are normally quite sprightly and into
everything they were very quiet very
subdued and I'd made a phone call to the
vets got myself an emergency appointment
in and took them in and then the vet
said to me I where we suspect it's parvo
virus explained everything to me and how
sort of infectious and contagious it is
to dogs and how deadly it is and just
said you know what you want to do
because suddenly a decision is yours and
it was a really hard decision
but like I say I couldn't let them
suffer any longer with very upset for
weeks and weeks and weeks because a
drifting of the upset at our I had the
other issues live that bills that I was
told recovered and wasn't insurance in a
prepared oh it's so I've been left now
with a three thousand pound that bill
that can't pair so it's not just the
aspects of pub farming it's it's all the
after-effects it's all very nice getting
a pop hair
what if the dog dies and you're left
with all these image of that bills
that's another distressing thing as well
everything that potentially could go
wrong with a tiny little fluffy puppy
could or will go wrong and the problem
with puppy farming is there's no
accountability what are the things you
do get across the board with these
people is just their absolute disregard
for these animals we've gone in there
dead puppies just lying around that have
been there for a couple of days we can
see there that the the live ones
obviously in with this dead dog evening
cars dead puppies in the foot whales of
top-of-the-range Mercedes
carry back what appears to be a dead
puppy these puppies are a commodity and
they don't see them in the way the the
buyer does for them it's about making
money so if they come down and they've
got a whole litter of dead dogs don't
care you know it's they cared because
they've lost some money we feel the
trade definitely if if people weren't so
determined to buy a particular type of
dog then this trade would despair
overnight from what I've seen a lot of
the demand for these type of dogs so
what people will call handbag dogs a lot
of that is social media driven celebrity
driven people see people they admire on
social media or on the television and
the illicit puppy farmers know that
that's why the majority of the breeds
that are coming into the country are
things like Pomeranians chill hours
this town is carrying sawdust
was they created a ring of Saudis bales
at the back of the vehicle from floor to
ceiling
they heated because that's where the
demand is to look extremely Q that can
be sold really really quickly
they'll be advertised on the internet
and sold within a day that's the problem
it's this ability to decide a buy dog
within the click of a mouse if you can
just get a puppy like that and and right
now I could make a phone call have a
puppy here in probably two hours
puppies probably sick pumped with drugs
to make it look well till tomorrow when
it dies the fact that you can do it that
easily means that I don't think people
really value dogs the way that they
should be valued again I've had I think
I've had a lot of time to think about
the number the sheer number of sick
puppies that are sold by these people
over a period of years it's also
estimated that somewhere around about
maybe 40 maybe even heading towards 50
percent of puppies are now farmed
puppies hello is that Lee when when
when's the soonest I could come to see
them that Stacy Hayward we hope that
we'll be able to to meet up and
what's going on there as well
long way to come
hello hello
[Music]
[Music]
is the boat rowing voice now status for
I think we were at the right place so
okay well I'll switch off anyway for now
hello is that Lee's friend sorry and we
will within about half an hour's drive
of her house when we got a call from
someone saying that unfortunately been
rushed into hospital I I think they they
seem to be if you like ducking and
diving to to try and wrong virtus and
they know that other people are finding
out more and more that awful trade that
they're a part of and and they know that
people are looking to expose them
everyone wants to raise awareness of
this awful vile trade and to stop them
doing what they're doing and so I think
they they're trying really hard to keep
one step ahead and they know that that
we're on the case and we're trying to
raise awareness Lucy I think most people
would like to think all people that look
dogs would never know any support puppy
farming so it's just important to really
highlight who are the dogs behind these
cute puppies that you're buying I think
sometimes people forget about the kind
of breeding dogs so I adopted Lucy in
the March 2013 and shortly after I set
up a Facebook page for her and it was
just really just to kind of document her
progress Ruby because she was so
malnourished and had obviously come from
such in a kind of abusive background so
when she was rescued she literally was
just a shell of a dog and they would
just kind of used to as much as they
possibly could to make as much money as
they could from her and it just really
kind of snowball to be honest people
could see obviously the changes in her
and it was just a kind of platform
really to not only share her soar
progress but also to just talk about
rescue dogs and in the hope that maybe
other people might think about then
adopting rather than goodbye in a dog if
they possibly could
well Lucy passed away in December 2016
and just all of a sudden she came very
poorly very quickly I'm so I continued
her page because I felt it was important
too because it was a page to obviously
still share stories of Lucy and people
would have wanted to still be seeing
pictures of Lucy but also the page was
there to raise awareness and the kind of
Lucy's law idea was a big sort of team
effort we wanted something that would
remember Lucy in a kind of fitting way
and I think is a fitting tribute to her
after all she kind of went through and
they went as she raised and it was just
we just thought what can we do that's
going to have a big impact on the buying
public and hopefully make a difference
to all the dogs sort of suffering on a
puppy farm so I think the campaign is
kind of just again like Lucy's patience
really snowball people have really got
behind it and want to people want to see
change it's you know hard work but it's
definitely worth it and it's definitely
getting the message out there and we
just hope obviously from from doing
Lucy's law that Lucy's life you know
will matter even more and it will be you
know the start of change for the dogs
but Lucy was one of those dogs who like
so many was bred from and bred from and
bred from and her puppies were sold on
and because it didn't feel very personal
people I don't think really grasped it
now it's really personal I think once
you have a real dog that represents a
campaign you're able to reach people
right here because it then really means
something it's not just a term you know
Lucy's law is the banning of commercial
sales of puppies from third parties so
that's the banning of puppies sold for
profit without their mum and away from
that where they were born it's this
whole argument about oh you're just
driver underground
well how many puppy buyers are actually
looking for an illegal pup on the dark
web right rubbish the reveal if you like
of certain organizations certain
high-profile animal welfare
organizations in the UK that have been
behind the scenes trying to stop
progress if they've been around that
long they've got all that money and all
that resource and the situation is
getting worse
and they've also got the ear of the
government something's not right and you
also realize that their profits depend
on dysfunctional dogs in the system and
of course they have links with the pet
industry what they're fighting for is
licensed third-party sellers so they're
saying as long as it's sold ok and
appropriately it's fine but we know it's
wrong whatever you do so third-party
selling is wrong and when you have
organizations not only barely publicly
admitting it because it's they know it's
wrong but their motives are very
different from people who genuinely love
animals and want the best thing for them
so it's uncomfortable for them you can
feel it they ignore a lot of questions
on Twitter they ignore a lot of emails
and it's because they're hopefully
ashamed of themselves puppies should
only be
from the breeder scene interacting with
their mum in the place they were born
and this is in line with number 10 with
the government's own advice you can keep
making excuses but at the moment
something needs to change it needs to
change now and to constantly delay
things you know the animals that it's
affecting are the dogs that are still
suffering so hopefully the government
will start to listen and hopefully sort
of the the people power will win through
and they'll see that there is a public
want vert for change for just so things
start to get a bit better for a
supposedly man's best friend how
difficult is it to sort of hold your
tongue when you're dealing with these
people you know treating dogs and such
ghastly way I think sometimes you've got
to look beyond that because it would be
it would be so easy to respond and and
to berate them and and say all the
things that you feel about them but
that's not gonna safe and he talks and
that's the most important thing
is to get these dogs cared for loved get
the veterinary treatment that they need
and give them a life because they
haven't got one previously has a huge
toll on me and and obviously on the
volunteers that work in the rescue the
other people that help with these
animals has a big impact but it's not
really about us is it it's about what we
can do to change the lives of these
animals even the ones that I haven't got
years but it's it's that in itself is
rewarding you know she's gonna dummy
with somebody who cares not in a shed
not in a bound somebody holding her and
talking to her she won't be alone and
and that's so important because every
animal deserves a good life but they
deserve a good death too and that's
something that we can give them and and
that might down sound defeatist and it
isn't at all but for some of them that's
all we can give them is a good death but
hopefully for most of them we can give
them years but what it will do is it
will slowly restrict the amount of dogs
coming into the country which will then
obviously increase the homegrown market
it will make the buyers happier because
the quality of the dog that they're
going to be buying is a bit more short
and equally across the board then you
need to stop these dogs being trucked
across Europe just to feed the UK market
if we can stop that then that's got to
be something positive and that would be
we're taking the right steps to actually
stop in this ridiculous trade that we've
got at the moment in terms of future
puppy sales and the welfare of puppies
Lucy's law quite simply would just
protect them people would know where
they were getting their dogs from people
would know exactly who bred them so
you're in a situation where you're
almost cleaning up the the dog dog
industry by forcing people to be respond
ethical moral and making that
potentially the biggest difference to
the future of dogs this country or the
world has ever seen
all our dreams come true if people like
this are never allowed to sell puppies
to the public again these are people who
have traded on misery for years they've
broken hearts along the way of what
they're doing and I wouldn't trust them
ever I mean people have always wanted an
end to puppy farming now they've got it
I like to go to sleep at night thinking
we are this close to making real change
see decisive action you know Lucy could
be the dog that saves every dog's life
and I genuinely believe she still can be
and what a tribute to a dog that went
through so much pain and suffering at
the hands of man and hopefully will come
out the other end as the dog that
actually changes the law it's incredibly
sad but it's also incredibly exciting at
the same time
[Music]
you
[Music]
you